so here at the Pete Holmes show we
hands-down have the best fans in the
world and I actually want it to show you
this video from a Canadian fan we have
named Rachel Spaulding take a look
my name is Rachel Spaulding and from
Ontario Canada Pete Holmes is my
absolute favorite comedian well Pete
Home Show is my favorite show and he's a
really big comedic inspiration my 15th
birthday is at the end of the summer
August 27th could it be possible that
give me a birthday shout-out on your
show and you realize I'm freaking yeah
in that video I am placing myself
directly right of fire and I'm ready to
be consulted that's very cruel but you
know what I'm willing to do it for the
possibility that you might see this so
sweet 15 happy birthday Rachel I
seriously wish we could afford to fly
you down for a taping but we don't have
any budget we can't even afford to have
me sing the Happy Birthday song cuz that
that you cost money it's like I can make
up dude August 27th in Ontario